let's go to william in vegas so william
in las vegas nevada you're on the air
william in las vegas nevada please
unmute yourself and then you'll be able
to talk to me
all right no william in vegas there very
very interesting
let's go to jojo in either austin or
australia i just see it says aus is it
austin texas or australia
no boy
austin australia you're on the air
no dice there let's try
jason from montreal you are on the air
hello david how you doing today good how
are you
doing pretty good um so i've been a fan
for multiple years i love your show
you've been doing a wonderful job at
covering everything in u.s politics
you're obviously my go-to show
pleasure um just wanted to uh make a few
points here basically so
uh republicans say they're pro-life
basically but their anti-universal
health care
anti-living wage anti-mass pro-war
anti-climate change
so basically they they're against taking
any action to sustain our planet past
their current generation so
other than banning abortion for you're
forgetting that they're they're they do
want to ban abortion yeah
definitely so i always thought it
wouldn't be wouldn't it be easier for
democrats to show how they're mo
more pro-life than republicans by saying
how they're easier
how therefore easier access to higher
paying jobs reducing match of
massive wage disparity in conserving
existing life
same could be applied with universal uh
with ubi basically so
i mean it seems like an easy point to be
arguing in u.s politics to be honest but
you are as you know one how many you're
10 correct you're 110
correct and it just has not worked
now whether it hasn't worked because
democrats are terrible at messaging
or it hasn't worked because it's not as
pithy but republicans george lakoff has
written about this a lot
republicans have been winning the
messaging war you are completely right
what is pro-life about a republican
platform pro-life just means
anti-abortion
but in terms of extending and improving
life on the planet
it is it is not i don't even want to
make it about party
it is not the right that is for those
things you're completely right and
due to a combination of republicans
getting
getting being early to the game of the
messaging and democrats being terrible
at messaging
it's it's proven more difficult than
what you're suggesting but you're
completely correct
definitely and i just wanted to make
another point here basically uh so my
girlfriend about two summers ago
i got um got pneumonia basically in the
middle of summer she could barely walk
without being out of breath
yeah she's had respiratory issues ever
since she was born so
we managed to get to a hospital she was
plugged into a veiled
ventilator on and off for about three
hours and we left basically with a
prescription for additional pumps
and a temporary one costing about 80
canadian which is absolutely nothing
um so without of course any
out-of-pocket costs i can't imagine how
much this would have cost
in the u.s basically you don't want to
know
you don't want to know it would have
been certainly thousands and thousands
of dollars
definitely it's really scary well thank
you very much david for for taking my
call i really appreciate it and uh have
yourself a wonderful day
my pleasure great to hear from you let's
take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because i'm going
right back to
viewer and listener calls right after
this short break
if one of your goals for the new year is
to cut back on carbs and sugar
check out one of our sponsors monk pack
monk pack keto granola bars fill you up
and taste like your favorite sweet
snacks
but they just have one gram of sugar
just two grams of net carbs at only 140
calories they have a soft
chewy texture and they come in delicious
flavors like coconut cocoa chip
peanut butter and maple pecan
or pecan or pecan it's all of the above
actually
they're perfect for a quick breakfast a
snack between
zoom calls or a late night treat not
only are they keto friendly they're
gluten-free
grain-free plant-based no soy trans fats
or sugar alcohols no artificial colors
and monk pack is so confident in their
keto snacks
that they back them with a hundred
percent money back guarantee
try it for yourself and you'll see how
delicious these are
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to monkpack.com and use coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video